So, you think what President Sunday did to Not So Erudite, you
think that that was fine?
>> Uh-oh. Are you Are you blacklisting me? I'm thinking
about disassociating myself from every community where Duby is
an active chatter. Where Duby is still on the server. I don't
think I can handle it anymore. Why did it get archived and deleted?
Um because I think you were threatening to dox and harass anyone
who posted in there.
a statement from the Snark Left. There's a Snark Left statement
today. My goodness.
Do the Discord channels make it public statements? Well, this
kind of had to be made unfortunately because when people are
lying about you, you do need to come together as a group and
just say something, okay? We'll read this real quick.
We'll read this one and then I'll go through my own thread and
then we can get on with the stream and laughing and having a
great time.
What What am I talking about? This server is a server I participate
in. A lot of the clippers are from this server. A lot of people
who chatter from this server. This is like a This is a server
where we are basically like it's like dark comedy, like a dark
comedy vibe, and we do a lot of clipping and research for videos
and stuff in the server. It's like a lot of content creators,
a lot of clippers, a lot of people who watch a lot of stuff.
Okay?
It's people who like content, who talk about content a lot. Okay?
And basically there are people who are trying to smear this community
and make it look bad, and I'm not interested in in furthering
those smears. Do you know what I mean? Okay. Hello, this is the
Snark Left, the Discord community started in September of last
year, created for clips, tweets, and commentary surrounding online
politics and drama. Our community consists of content creators,
editors, clippers, chatters, and more. Recently we've been faced
with certain accusations surrounding the nature of our community,
and we want to take a moment to address these concerns. Unequivocally,
our community does not and never has condoned or endorsed doxxing,
invasions of privacy, or otherwise exposing the personal information
of any of the subjects of the discourse or anybody. We take these
matters seriously, and the The of the community is staunchly
opposed to participation in these behaviors.
Following recent public discussions about our server, we took
some time to review many of our chat logs, and we discovered
two instances of improper disclosure of PII, personally identifiable
information, in our server. The first was an incident only a
few weeks after the server opened, when there was minimal moderation
or
This incident regrettably went unnoticed by server ownership.
The second incident was deleted immediately, the same minute
minute it was posted. Both users are permanently banned from
the server and are not welcome back. Since our culture is so
clearly opposed So, furthermore, we want to make it clear we
have nothing to hide because our culture is so clearly opposed
to these behaviors, we recognize these accusations for what they
are, a bad faith attempt to create a false equivalence. Painting
our entire community as a doxing server is transparently just
a tactic to discredit our commentary and shield the subjects
of our criticism from accountability.
There's going to be some parallels here, okay? We look forward
to continuing to engage in critical satirical commentary, promoting
the work of our community members, and most importantly,
Starking. Stark snark. Stark Stark snark. Apparently, there's
a funny Stardust monologue. Give me a second. So, a couple of
things to keep in mind here. For [snorts] the past year and a
half, people have been sweeper hunting, which is basically
if you have been associated with Destiny at any time at any point,
uh people were doing this thing for the past year and a half
where they would show up in your chats and demand that you disavow
Destiny and disavow everything, right? And to you know, it didn't
matter if you disagreed with his actions, it didn't matter if
you criticized him for his actions, it didn't matter if you'd
recently collaborated with him. They would show up in your chat
demanding you say something Dude, I don't I literally don't care.
Like, Stardust needs to just stop
Just stop coping.
By the way, there's lots of people who associate with Destiny
on a lot of different grounds, right? The sad thing about Stardust
is she just hates me and Kwebbelkop. She just hates the people
who don't like Destiny. She doesn't actually like Destiny. That's
even worse. If you at least had a relationship with Destiny,
if he gave a about you, this would be less pathetic.
But it's so much more pathetic when I know it's just a petty
personal
Like just admit that that's what you're doing. When you say,
"Um, these guys all pretend they're better." You're just running
Dan's narrative.
That's what Dan's been trying to say. These guys pretend they're
better, but they're not. Uh, but we are though.
But we like actually are. Cuz here's the
at minimum, we have the principle and if if something around
us fails in the principle, we call it out and we cut it
Why is Why are all these people pretending that when they say
they they say they don't have principles, that makes them better?
Actually, I'm just not lying to you.
It's [clears throat] the inverse of the hypocrisy thing. The
hypocrisy and what is it? It's the inverse of the hypocrisy
comment or or joke from Norm Macdonald, that's who it is. You
know, the the thing about Cosby? Like, you know, Pat Oswalt says
to me, "The worst part is the hypocrisy." It's like, "No, the
worst part is the
Well, guess what?
The worst part isn't the hypocrisy or failing in a standard occasionally.
The worst part is the bad conduct and the bad conduct that you
say you're unapologetic about. So, don't try to compare us. We're
not the same. Shut up.
Jeez. Can I ask what you hate about Destiny and Point Forum?
I don't know your past beefs well enough. He threatens anybody
who basically steps against him in almost any way. Like if you
are pointing out a moral flaw of his, he will threaten you naturally.
Uh, he threatened Anavar. He threatened to basically, when his
whole community is coming down on Anavar, he threatened to leak
her nudes if she basically said what she's right now while she
was being called a stalker by a bunch of people, right? There's
a whole bunch of things like that. If you criticize this guy,
he will threaten you. I criticized him, he threatened to dox
He just threatens immediately, right? And in a lot of cases,
he actually follows through. He's a sick, sick, twisted person.
There, I actually did it really fast. There you go. something
about Destiny, as if you hadn't. Right? You
It It basically they were looking for sweepers so that they could
basically
arrest them, right? And as somebody who's like already on the
outs or outside of that community, like it didn't really matter
whether I was a sweeper or not. They were already labeling me
as a sweeper
despite the fact that as soon as the stuff with Pixie exploded,
I was very critical of Destiny for his actions in that. Riding
the waves with the Oreo, right? That's all it was. And just because
I didn't want to make my entire life about destroying his life.
No, that's not required. >> Or even This is just totally
made up. Oh, just cuz I didn't want to make my whole life about
destroying his life. I have a bunch of friends who literally
refuse to talk about Destiny. I wonder why? I wonder why they're
all so scared to say something. But I've got a bunch of friends
like that. What are we talking about? I've got a a whole bunch
of friends who want nothing to do with any of this [__]
That's totally fine.
Why is she pretending this isn't about her coming out and explicitly
trying to minimize his wrongdoing by bringing everybody else
down to the same level? That's what she was called the sweeper
for, and that is an accurate statement. You are a sweeper. Stop
coping. circling around his life. Like I was labeled as a sweeper,
which is insane. And what happens to sweepers? They get harassed
and they get doxed, right? And if they determine that you're
enough of a sweeper or they get enough evidence of it, they'll
they'll just dox you, right? So, for the past year and a half,
people have been doing that, and it's like a guilt by association
thing,
And the point of this call that we're about to listen to is there
has been discovered the Snark server, a splinter Discord server
where people are doxing people, um coordinating harassment, coordinating
smear campaigns,
and Contend with the criticism, point out what the criticisms
are lies or false, contend with the criticisms. That's what you
got to do. Discontent with the criticisms. Again,
we operate That community operates on the Cat Piss Manifesto
standard. You're responsible for the things you do. If people
break the rules, and doxing is against the rules, they will be
banned. Show me an instance of somebody of it going unmoderated
outside of the one that's in September where we like missed it,
right?
Otherwise, [__] off. Don't pretend that one member
of your community doing something bad over months and months
and months is indicative of that entire community. I say we cuz
I don't like minimizing like my
the membership of the group, obviously.
Right? Stop. Just stop. If If we're banning people if they do
something like this, that's the line. That's the standard. You
have to inform me and let me moderate it.
This whole thing where it's like, "Oh, we actually know this
is all happening, but we will never prove it." [__]
off,
[__] off. Oh, and actually, hold on.
There is another thing that I wasn't necessarily going to say,
but I wouldn't say I don't feel bad for people who do get their
information revealed if they've done bad acts. I I won't say
I don't feel bad for them. I basically almost always feel empathy
for people even if they're really
But I don't know how you participate in these communities for
the past 14 months as Destiny has gone on a doxing campaign providing
no evidence for that doxing campaign targeting me, Queen Man,
my
just a bunch of people, a bunch of different people, right? And
you don't speak up and demand the evidence. None of you guys
spoke up and demanded the evidence. Not a single one of you said,
"We need to see that evidence, or I will not engage with you
anymore." And it's led to where we've gotten to now in terms
of escalations. And so, while I do feel bad for you guys getting
your information exposed, and I would never support somebody
doing that, you have to understand that you played the most pivotal
role in that happening to you. You could have come out and said,
"Actually, Destiny, I'm not going to I will literally block you
from everything and never interact with you again unless you
show me why you're doing this." And it's never happened. Not
a single one of these people stood up and said, "Hey, this is
wrong and we can't just let you punish people or or try to meet
out punishment to people without evidence. If anybody had stood
on business and said and drawn a a bright line in the
you wouldn't be here now.
You're here now because you've been appeasing this lunatic for
14 months or something now at this point.
That's why we've gotten to where we've gotten to.
I got I don't care about Star Hust. It's our last day of this
stuff, guys, and then we're going to I just got to I just got
to watch Duby style on people, okay? I just got to watch some
Duby. >> we're doing a lot of drama, okay? I'm trying to
have this drama going for days and days. Um are you going to
recap the Duby stuff from the VC last night / this morning? I
don't think there were recordings floating out there. It's just
one of the Dude, it's he is like so he can't cover it on his
stream. He does not want this in a VOD on his stream, that conversation.
That conversation is like crazy. The one of the conspiracies
that people spread about me is that like the second I found out
this girl that was involved in my lawsuit was underage, the moral
and upstanding citizen thing to do would have been I needed to
go to the FBI, give them a whole bunch of and say, "Here, FBI,
like I think you guys need to investigate all of this stuff because
um I you know, I want to be a good Samaritan." How like just
it's like the most thing in the universe, okay? I tried asking
Duby a couple examples of like would you ever do this? And like
Duby was saying that like um
Duby was saying that I think the Duby was saying that he did
it. Duby was saying that he had multiple examples. Duby gave
you multiple examples of doing it, actually.
Give them a whole bunch of So, you had a whole bunch of then.
They just WANTED ME TO GO GIVE MY TO THE COPS. NO, it's mine.
It's mine. Gross. Gross behavior. >> I said? I said if
you if you have a friend who gives you like a ton of [__]
and it ends up being like a bunch of drugs or something and then
you realize it's a bunch of drugs. Like would you take all of
these drugs to the cops and go, "Hey cops, I have like kilos
of or whatever. Um I just wanted to like give this to you and
let you know that like there's a bad guy out there, but I didn't
actually Hold on. That's a weird example. You might not have
to go to the cops with that depending on what you could do, right?
Like you could just report your friend. The issue is here
you need like the evidence to get the like somebody could be
getting harmed. You you have said the solo guy is an international
trafficker. He could be harming more young girls, right? That's
the framing you gave us. If that is your framing that this guy
is potentially very harmful to a bunch of other people on the
internet,
then you you should, yes, obviously do that. He wanted any of
it, but he just gave it to me. Like it it it's just like the
most thing. It's just like the Yo, teach chatter. Thank you for
the 30 months. Let's go. >> like all these stupid
hypotheticals to run down. And then the thing that I have the
issue that I have is that Doobie will spend like I I just jumped
into the beginning of stream. Doobie was also in that Discord
server this morning talking about me. I think he was in that
Discord server last night talking about me. Doobie spends hours
and hours and hours and hours and hours
like an Patriot. Patriot. Doobie. Doobie's a patriot.
Patriot. in all these servers I'm in. >> okay? Um I think
I'm probably for the first time like I'm close to this. I have
to think about it a little bit more tonight, but for the first
time I think I'm probably going to
enforce
a no contact thing, but I don't know if it's going to be like
cutting out like Wick or Connor or whatever >> Oh, here
we go. Here we go. So, Destiny comes on his stream today and
he goes, "Guys, today
I'm really going to do a blacklist today. I know I've copped
out every other time I've ever done a blacklist ever, but like
today I'm really going to do a blacklist today, okay? Today is
a real blacklist day. I mean it. I'm I'm not just infinitely
raging. I mean it. I mean it. I mean it. I might just cut people
out who still allow Doobie to go to their servers and talk and
talk and talk and talk and talk about me being a whatever for
hours and hours and hours because it's not just that too. Like
I've heard him make this argument multiple times and he was doing
it again this morning to where um Doobie argues that like if
I'm in favor of doxxing or unmasking certain people, Jesus, hold
Okay, sorry. Never mind. If I'm in favor of like doxxing or unmasking
certain people because I think that like I think that this identity
is relevant. I don't think this person should be able to do something
for 20
uh you know, months of stalking me uh and completely be able
to walk away from it and like there's no identity. It's just
like a faceless person. I think that's crazy, right? Um he his
argument is that well, couldn't one of these people whose names
that you uncover, couldn't they have like a family? And if that
person has a family, you're basically doxxing a family, which
means that you're uh you're basically
creating a world where I think it would actually be permissible
to dox my son and his mom. Like he's around here making these
I structure um permission
permission structure for people to [__] with an atheist
and just [__] with his mom and I don't agree with
that to be
Oh. Oh, like when you dox adjacents of people, you are creating
a permission structure for people to go after your adjacents,
right? When you when you dox collateral targets to the people
you're upset with, you are creating a permission structure to
go after your own collateral targets. Yes, absolutely. That's
That's just obviously true. If you're somebody who engages in
an action and most people say, well, I think that action is wrong,
you will get a significant number of people who will not hold
their principle and will say, no, I'm going to do the thing back
to you that you're doing to me. That like principally, it's not
good, but obviously, you are like for other people to go, well,
that's totally wrong to do,
but you do the thing, right? It's very difficult. I think Destiny
has even agreed with this in the past. He agreed with it in the
doctrine front, yeah. He said yes to this. Like while while Kweiman
argued that, I think Kweiman argued that in the He did a video
response to Willy, right? Like that is the Destiny argument is
I can go after all of these adjacent. I'll threaten all of these
adjacent, and you just have to deal with it.
Yeah. That's That's just on the He put that on the board. Now,
we don't do that because it's wrong to do that, but he's the
one who put that on the board. It's It's It's just I don't think
any of it should be happening. But I just want to be clear like
if if that is what the world that he's he is creating, like I
don't think he has any ground to complain about it. Well,
wait. So, uh first there's like two things here. It's just like
whenever like we're talking about some like unhinged person's
behavior, you're always pointing out like, well, but kind of
like but Destiny did this. And then it doesn't even seem that
equivocal. Where did Destiny tell you it's okay to dox people's
families, children, or any of that? Like it's It's just a loose
connection where this guy is like directly saying
I mean, hold on. I can see Oh, he presented this so disingenuously,
didn't he? He's like, actually it gives you a permission structure
to like go after my son. I'm guessing what Doobie's going to
say is, technically, it's giving you a permission structure to
go after like adjacent content creators, but if those people
had kids, then you would be doxing the location of them, right?
If if that were to happen. Like if you were if somebody were
targeted and they had a family, and their information was posted
online, well, their family are now like openly at risk. That's
the problem. saying like, hey, it's okay to like Yeah, it's okay
to like target If if you get or what you're saying is basically
in by Destiny's standards, it's
by Destiny's standard it it an internal critique of the people
who associate with Destiny, right? That you're you're associating
with a community that has these standards, and so you are opting
into something, you basically have no right to complain. Right?
If something immoral is done to you. Now, I don't engage in that.
People around me don't engage in that. But like these people
when they get up in arms about this, it's like, "Dude, you you
opted into this." And like I said earlier, I actually feel bad
for these people who have had their PII exposed. I do. But if
you guys had stood up to business months ago, months and months
and months ago and said, "Hey, you you can't come on my stream
until you show evidence for this while you're like doxing people."
If I'm not going to associate until you show evidence for this.
If all these people had done that,
they wouldn't be in this situation.
They didn't do the right thing. They made an immoral choice.
And that immoral choice has led to now.
And so while I feel bad for them, and I don't advocate for any
of those things to happen. In fact, I advocate the opposite.
I would say, "Hey, you actually hurt the the people who are on
the other side of this are probably hurt actually by PII being
exposed to people who are adjacent to Destiny. That he uses that
to isolate people or to sorry, insulate people to push them further
onto his side of things, right?"
Like I would say, both pragmatically and morally it's wrong.
But I I don't I don't control the people who do it, so I can't
make them stop. I would like for them to stop. I Okay. Hold on.
I got sent some screenshots of
I think I got I got sent some screenshots here real quick of
this argument, okay? So there was an argument between Big Nick,
Erudite's husband, Big Nick. Almost people told me he said, "You
said people are justified in going after Destiny's kid." On the
doxing thing, I think any large internet community is going to
be full of nut bags who do dumb Doxing is and should be a taboo
with zero tolerance in online spaces for this
Over the last couple years, Destiny's been openly engaging in
doxing and encourage the encouragement of her of doxing. Oh,
he claims this is in retaliation. I claim that isn't true. I've
never doxed him or encouraged anyone to do that or hung around
people doing it. Now we continue. His behavior has broken the
taboo in a way that we we haven't seen in these spaces. We just
haven't seen it in these spaces. So, if he's going to behave
this way, understanding that the these spaces are full of nut
bags on all sides who might endanger the families and loved ones
of his enemies, he should expect it to happen to him. I don't
think any of it is justified. I think it's all bad and everyone
should stop. I think even if he's doing it to other people, people
should not do it to him and especially not his friends or family.
I've absolutely never supported involving his son and family
in any of this stuff and I never would.
Okay? Okay? Okay? Okay? And basically Nick comes back and says,
"Wait, I should clarify. Are you saying that he has no right
to complain or that he should blame himself? I think those are
substantially different. I'm not sure which one you mean." Um
he is to blame for creating the permission structure and
those are the same, right? You have no right to complain because
you have a lot of blame in the situation. I think the Are those
really different? I'm trying to I'm not even thinking about why
those are different. To me, on its face, I'm like, "No, the reason
he should blame himself or the reason he shouldn't complain is
because it's like at least partially, largely his fault. Like
he has basically made it so other people get this like feeling
that he deserves it and they go after him, right? But if it's
all taboo as it's been for a very long time, you see far less
of this stuff occurring."
It's no It's normal when you like Destiny. More normal than shoe
stalker. Haha. Okay, not just by it. Yeah, I can use myself as
an example. I've been to the multiple actually dangerous criminal
orgs for a decade now who have made serious threats against my
family and I. Destiny's encouraging people to doxx my family
or doxx me puts my family Destiny's encouraging people to doxx
me puts my family at risk. Me, too, but I care less about that.
I think you would understand if I reacted to that danger in a
very aggressive, violent, or problematic way. But I will not
do it because I'm mentally stable I'm a mentally stable person
and I've done enough to feel decently safe from the doxxing threats.
But not everyone is me. So, like I don't know, seems like he's
playing with fire. I hope my last statement clears it up a bit.
It's not what I think It's not that I think any of this is justified.
It's more that I think his behavior is fueling this kind of unhinged
behavior, and he needs to stop fueling it. Yep. Destiny needs
to be the bigger human. Is he capable? Literally never.
Destiny is incapable of being the bigger bigger human both because
of his stature and like morally, he's just He will always lower
himself below whoever he's going against, right? He'll always
lower the standard. He always lower the bar every single time.
So, I think from here we can go forward. We now got the his whole
reiterating of the blacklist. All right, 1 hour 36 11, he's apparently
confronting the
Let's see.
The next time stamp I've got.
Stacey is in Wick Court right now.
Oh, boy. Who's Stacey? [laughter] One of the unhinged gesticulators.
Wait, [snorts] why are all of these people just I don't By the
way, I think that's Wait,
Just being like a uh Oh my god, is that what you actually sound
like? Holy [__]
What are we doing? Are we doing more reputation rehab for you
guys in here? Is that what's going on? Yeah. Uh we're going over
this tweet that Stacey or this uh Discord log looks like uh Stacey
had here.
>> Is he Is he streaming right now? Are we >> We
sure are. Are they Are they in a streamable Discord when they're
doing this, by the way? Does anyone know if they're in a streamable
Discord while this is happening? Is Wick just going to totally
kneel on his own rules here? I actually like Mr. Moon. Uh yeah,
no, we were just talking about how this snarker left's Discord's
now open. And uh trying to figure out uh why would we want to
go over there? Wait, so just curious, Stacey, why did uh Sava
never get banned from Jessica's Discord server for harassing
the victim of my court case? Did you ever talk to Jessica about
it?
I don't think so. And Chuck, you wouldn't say anything? You would
just be like, oh, it's over. Yeah, I would probably repull that,
but like in terms of having Cybert there, I don't know what what
the correlative there is. Well, the correlative is him posting
emails of him harassing a crime's victim and then people like
you responding favorably to
Well, I responded favorably before I knew what all of the emails
were.
What? So, So, I I I I I I I I I I I I I I I I I I I I I I I I
I I I I I I I I I I I I I I I I I I I I I I I I I I I I I I I
I I I I I I I I I I I I I I I I I I I I I I I I I By the way,
this is what Destiny does is we didn't even know Cybert had contacted
like any family or anything. It just looked like he was letting
her know you got doxxed and here's how you take your [__]
down. at all cuz I think it got archived or deleted or whatever.
Why did it get archived and deleted? >> Um because I think
you were threatening to doxx and harass anyone who posted in
Let's go. Let's go. Yes. That is That is it. We basically I was
basically playing with the idea that maybe if we don't have the
shadow anymore, maybe this guy will stop being a total psycho.
Maybe. Maybe. Maybe. Are you making it up? Successfully doing
that with eSports Batman, right? I don't think I ever did, did
I? Did I find him?
>> Did I I don't think I did that. I don't think I did
that. Oh, not so Suddenly, the guy, once he knows that we're
willing to report him for for his doxxing his crowing about his
doxxing and how effective it is, suddenly he's like, oh, uh I'm
not going to say anything about this on YouTube.
Oh, so now you think it's wrong? I thought you were the guy who
was honest about this, Destiny. I thought you were out in the
open about this.
Loser. Presumably, you did post this doxx. You did put it into
DGG chat. You did say, "Here's eSports Batman's information,
lmao." Okay. I just don't remember. But if I did, I mean, Did
what? I don't Did I do that? Oh, I don't remember if I did that.
He's a lawyer. He's credentialing himself. I think it's okay
for him to be unmasked to have a person Don't call it unmasking.
You are publishing it publicly for the purpose of harassment.
It's not unmasking. You Dude, he's doing the Israel thing. This
guy, as he spirals further and further into his his own mania,
he becomes more like Israel, okay? It's that It's that curse
that burned the Israel patch into his beard. It's just like his
actions become more and more Israeli over time. Now he's like
doing the the language games, right? I just unmasked people.
I didn't I didn't dox. I just unmasked. I It was unmasking.
Are Are we unmasking? >> who is standing by their credentials
and then using that to weigh in on a court case? I think that's
totally fair. We can disagree on that. That's fine. So, do you
think it was acceptable? What emails do you think were acceptable
for members of a Antifa Discord to be shooting off to a victim
in my court members of an Antifa He wasn't operating as a member
of the
He was operating on his own. Yes. Like what kind of emails do
you think would have been okay that you were supporting before
you knew what they actually were? I didn't have any of the details
of the emails. I think it was literally just a
this person like removed As far as I was aware at the time when
I said it, it was like uh well, what's the word? Reciprocal.
It It wasn't like harassment in any to any degree as I understood
at the moment.
You don't think it's fair that somebody could identify themselves
as a lawyer and then weigh in on a court case
uh in a community that has been like publicly and privately engaging
with said court case and it's okay for that person to remain
anonymous the entire time despite credentialing themselves? I
don't think that's worthy of a dox. No. I I think you should
be able to weigh in on basically anything with If you have a
problem with that, you could find their identity and report them,
right? Wouldn't that be the direction you go? If you If you really
truly had a problem with it and felt they were giving some opinion
that was worthy of of like raising a stink about, why wouldn't
you just report them? There is no justification for publishing
it except to harass them out of
This guy gets that that pointy cone cap and he gets to sit in
a corner all day. Hey, dunce.
Obviously, there's no reason to publish it publicly, you weird
loser.
Like, every single time he's doxxed somebody, which he has doxxed
people, right? Not unmask people, but doxxed them, because he
publishes the identity publicly for the purpose of harassment.
He's like the ding-dong guy, yeah. He's got the dunce cap. >> Some
level of anonymity.
You think you should be able to credential yourself? >> should
be able to commit I don't think you should be able to commit
crimes, but I think you should be able to like publicly say something
about something, yeah. And you after credentialing yourself?
What counts as credentialing? I could be completely anonymous.
I could say I'm a lawyer. I could completely [__]
lie. >> say you're let's say you're a doctor and you want
to comment on a medical thing. You're like, "Well, I'm a doctor,
you know, I'm a practicing physician." Do you think it'd be fair
for somebody, especially if you're actively commenting on a on
a community that's actively engaged with it? There's no reason
to publish it. You could have verified their lawyer. If you If
you're worried about that, you could have verified their lawyer
and said, "Yep, they're a lawyer." Which you've already done
in the past. You know that he's a lawyer because your platform
verified him as a lawyer. Lying scum.
Oto lying scum again. You knew he was a lawyer. You knew for
a fact he was a lawyer. You weren't looking it up. You weren't
trying to find out if he was a lawyer or not. You knew that for
a fact. He was literally verified on your platform. He has been
in your community for like 15 years. You are degenerate lying
scum.
that. You don't think it's fair for people to like, "Well, who
are you?" I think that's kind of like an important thing to know
if you're going to credential yourself as a physician. I think
it's like publicly worthwhile to you know, at least the knowledge
this person is who they say they are. No?
So, you knew that this person was a lawyer before you had their
information? Not 100%. I mean, he says he is, but
So, then anyone who says that they're a lawyer online and they
comment on any particular case whatsoever, you think that that's
fair game to like doxx them I think that if they are credentialing
them You just called again for a Pisco's doxx cuz he's a sick
And they're they're like tons and tons of active conversations
about a particular thing, I think it's fair to unmask that person,
yes. If somebody shows up in one comment and they're like "Hey
guys, I'm a lawyer. This seems like kind of, you know, kind of
weird or whatever." and like that's it, probably not. But if
somebody like for hundreds of thousands of lines of text is constantly
giving an opinion and feedback on like ongoing motions and everything
related to a court case that a community is like actively, literally
actively participating in the court case in, I think it's super
fair to know like that is that person at least the lawyer that
they say they are? I think that's fair, yeah. So, just published
that they're a lawyer. You verified it. Why Why would you need
to do anything beyond just go "Okay, this guy is a lawyer. He
can make these comments."? Why did you have to publish his identity?
Why did you publish his
Why would you do that, Destiny?
It's obviously just to harass somebody, right? Is Yuri a sick,
degenerate pervert who enjoys hurting people? And we're just
here to watch and and comment and make a record.
We'll keep doing that. So, you think what President Sunday did
to No So Erudite, you think that that was fine? What do you think
my issue was with the President Sunday?
The No So Erudite stuff.
>> I'm I'm asking you now.
My understanding was the stupid thing about the President Sunday
thing was I think Kyla says she I don't even remember this. It's
she was like she I don't even remember, but like I think it was
something like uh It's like a master's in econometrics
and then President Sunday with
>> Is he performing this? He has to be, right? There's
no way his memory's this That's like his friend. That's somebody
who's supposed to be like his friend. If If my friend couldn't
even get remotely close to the degree I have, like to the credentials
I'm I'm claiming I have,
I would This person has no investment in you. Either he's lying
to pretend he doesn't remember all that well, or he's just not
that invested in Erudite, the person who's like constantly gone
to bat for him over years and years and years.
Like yeah, his podcast co-host, his like long-time friend, he
just doesn't give a That's very funny to me. >> Was trying
to expose her as actually only having like a graduate honors
post thing in econo psych.
>> Dude. Dude, there's no way. Dude, if Stardust was doing
this to him, he would lose his mind, guys. >> it metrics.
It was like the whatever. This was like the thing about the whole
President Sunday But isn't Kyla's name like a totally graduate
honors post thing in econo psychometrics. It was like the whatever.
This was like the thing about the whole President Sunday But
isn't Kyla's name public? It wasn't. Or at least she was saying
it wasn't. So, they were saying that Sunday doxxed her. So, you
would just totally disagree that Sunday doxxed Kyla. Therefore,
like every argument made about that whole drama, you absolve
Sunday of. Okay, thank you. That was the argument. They were
saying Sunday like doxxed this
Okay, well, I All right. >> was public. I think what
President Sunday was trying to do was verify
uh what she was like doctored in or whatever, and then trying
to figure out exactly like what she could consider herself, and
that he made the allegation that she was lying about what she
was labeling herself, right? >> Sure. Which I don't really
think was
I I don't know to the tenacity of that. I'm just double-checking
that the standard is is that if you claim to be something and
you're commenting on things cuz Kyla would often say, "Oh, as
a say whatever she called herself." I don't remember the two
terms that President Sunday was trying to identify.
By the way,
by the way, would this not also go to the Nicandro's argument,
the Nicandro's and Chimmu argument along looking up information
on somebody because you have like concerns about them? So long
as you don't publish it, right? Like it's not Destiny would have
to argue was it improper for Sunday to look into this, >> You're
saying like that that behavior is fine. Trying to figure out
exactly what that is, and then trying to speak on that with your
credentials is actually fine to go and look that information
up.
If somebody's credentialing themselves in like mental health
or whatever, sure.
Uh I I don't have much else time. Okay. Have a good night. >> Have
fun. Good luck talking about me for hours and hours in VCs more.
Bye. Are you uh are you blacklisting me? I'm thinking about dissociating
myself from every community where Dubious is an active chatter
where Dubious is still on the server. I don't think I can handle
it anymore.
I understand
your point here, and I actually agree with it that these people
going in and kind of creating these rumors constantly and spreading
like and basically litigating
why you are evil 24/7 is is a problem. I I agree with you 100%.
By the way, I would assume Dubious like me. I'll go in and just
chill. But the problem is the cultists can't just chill if you're
there. They see an evil name, and they have to come fight you,
right? That's the That's the real issue. I'm totally fine not
discussing the stuff, but if I go in any VC that's like in some
neutral
the cultists have to come in and like fight you immediately.
Like they see my name in one of those spaces, they're immediately
in there like, "You're a piece of me." Do you, man? Do you, man?
It's so funny. Anyway,
I I Guys, I Destiny, uh
if you're blacklisting me, and uh I just want to say I would
you be doing that? I just don't think that that's like a very
good question, a very good solution to our problem here, Destiny.
I just don't Yeah. I mean,
I don't think it helps or will fix any issue by just blacklisting
anyone that has any of these people in their server, right? I
disagree. I think that's I think it's a really effective way
of doing things, and I think that's why that's their MO. Like
that's their entire goal, right? What is Do you agree that Dubi
is trying to enforce a form of blacklist against me with the
way that he donates to people, right?
I I think he's pressuring you. I don't know if I'd say blacklisting,
but it's a definitely a pressure campaign and manipulation campaign.
I agree with >> money, with thousands of dollars of money,
right?
Sure, but it hasn't worked in my case, right? Like this is something
that they've been doing not just for a month, not just for a
couple months, but for over a year now.
I should point out that when Destiny did hot drop into that VC,
I do believe
they were talking not about him.
Were they Maybe it's a different one. Maybe it's a different
one later in the day. I think he's done this a couple times,
so >> harassing me basically and trying to get me to ban
you uh and to not have you on. Uh constantly harassing me by
with my own principles. Jeb Ted just keeps harassing me with
my own principles. Dubi just keeps harassing me with my own stated
principles. It's harassment to point out that I've totally changed
on this topic. This is deranged harassment. >> either by
directly saying that like a few community members uh or as Dubi
does and say, "I'm just not going to donate to you when you have
Destiny on." Um that hasn't worked in my case. And so if you're
going to blacklist
people where communities this happens, I think you should probably
make an exception for communities where it does not work. And
I think that Yeah, but what the problem is when you say does
not work, the issue is that like [laughter] these people are
Dude. Dude, what the Hold on. I was giving a I was giving a meme
just for this moment. Hold on. Hold on. The Jeb Ted meme, Jeb
Ted threw this up, okay?
>> Oh, suck your You want to eat your I'll eat your
That's it's basically Wick when he is confronted with Destiny,
okay? He'll do anything. He'll do anything.
Just don't
Just don't blacklist me. Just Just don't blacklist me.
Please. so active. Didn't you see the thread? I'm on your team
now. Didn't you see the thread? in these communities talking
and talking and talking and they will bring their friends in
to talk and talk and talk. Like it was happening a few months
ago. Some people notice it. I think the only like really well
moderated community that like protects against this stuff is
Loner Boxes. Some people notice it but like four or five will
join at the same time. They'll be in these VCs constantly talking
about me. And now like at this point in my life where The thing
where that he's talking about right now is me joining Loner Boxes
Discord to hang out with Marutzi and playing World of Warcraft.
And then if people wanted to argue with me, I'd argue about politics.
That's what I was there for. It was just to argue about politics,
right? Bring people in to argue with me. I wouldn't even I would
explicitly try not to bring it up as a topic. I would try. >> it
has had like a severe negative like impact on like these people
are direct participants in my court case right now. That's letting
a actual trafficker just like run free in the UK because they're
How does he say this today? After what he said to Duby last night,
how does he moralize on this? Letting this trafficker run free.
How does he How does he moralize it? How? How? How? We just listened
to a VC last night where he's like, "Yeah, of course I'm not
going to go to the cops with this, Sam. That would be crazy.
I could get arrested for
Of course I'm not going to go to Dude, >> obsessed with
like trying to talk about me and participate in my case all the
time. I I just don't know why I would want anything to do with
communities where these people are just for 10 hours a day. You
can't fight against it. It's too much. It's too much to constantly
have somebody here. Like these people are relitigating the Anna
Vor drama every single day. Cuz you lied about it and you got
her to lie about it by remaining friends with her and now she
sees it clearly.
You literally commented on this. Britney Simon leaked this about
you, right? >> 8-hour VCs. I get sent so many recordings.
Did you know there was another 7-hour VC last night in this politics
room? There was another 6-hour VC in Peace Coast. There was another
5-hour VC in Carter's. There was another 7-hour VC in Wix. Duby
was in there last night. Oh, you know how Vickers kept bringing
up like didn't you do this? Wasn't this part of the mystery report?
That was Doobie sending messages to him because he was in that
voice chat. And then he was there chatting for hours and hours
after the debate. He was there this morning for when I woke up
still talking about me. And then before I went to stream he was
also in there talking about me. Like yeah, I'm sorry. Look, I
I'm I'm going to be very clear with you. I 100% am on your side
and I do not agree with Doobie and what he is doing. But Doobie
has been part of my community for since since it began, since
it started. Um he is often in my VC and has been since it started
just to chat. He Wick knows that if he like that his community
might just end up following Doobie around. >> often talks
about you but not always talks about you. Now, if you'd like,
I can consider something like banning unless you're on my stream
not letting them talk about you, right? Like so if they do start
uh litigating
uh oh, did you hear about what Destiny did XY and Z? Maybe we
can put a nix on that. But asking me to ban someone who hasn't
broken my rules, I don't I I'm just not going to do that. Yeah,
I don't know. Maybe I'll think about it. But the the issue is
the way these people operate is like if somebody says something
good about me in one of these VCs, they're all going to be in
their side Discords like sniping at the person, talking about
the person. In some Discords maybe doxing the person. >> shown
me the evidence that this is the case. I 100% agree with this.
Yes. Yeah, but then why like I just don't know why I would want
to be associated
Like it's just like it's so much. Like
Dude, I
What does Wick decide? I feel like Wick knows that his community
like quickly disintegrates if he gets rid of Doobie and Jab and
a bunch of these people at the same time, right? He's got to
know that. I think. I think he's got to know that, >> know.
It's just like a lot. It's just It's a lot. It's a lot. I get
it.
But But you understand like the on my side of on my end of things,
right? And I I I get that like th- this isn't something like
you have to be altruistic for or anything like that. But like
I do have a certain set of rules. I do have a certain set of
values. And one of my values is I allow people to have discussions
in my server about even if I 100% disagree with them. Like again,
this is something that they have advocated in my Discord over
and over again in a pressure campaign against me, which again
has not affected It doesn't have the same ramifications towards
me as it does towards you. I understand that. I'm not on trial.
I don't have a court case pending. But it is something that they
have been pressuring me that has affected me. But like one of
my one of the reasons initially
I took your side before knowing anything is because they were
asking me to ban others and you were not. And I'm always going
to side with this the the people at least Well, wait, who were
they asking you to ban? I think they were just asking you to
ban the person who was doing the doxing, no? Wasn't Wasn't the
person they want to ban just Destiny because he was doxing people
actively?
I thought that was the only person that would Were they asking
to ban someone
Is Is Wick pretending that they were pressuring like Wick to
ban DG community members? At least initially who say, "Hey, uh
you can do what you want. We're not going to try to to uh pressure
you or manipulate you in any way, shape or form." Um and That's
fine then. In that case, my my only request then I guess would
be to not ban the um streaming in that room cuz now I'm just
going to set an alert up and if anytime these are talking about
me, I don't give a [__] if I'm sleeping. I don't
care if I'm at my future wife's having a birth in the hospital.
Dude, oh my god. Could you imagine being like a big streamer
and saying this out loud? Bro, that's crazy. That's insane.
Anytime people are talking about me, anyone on the internet,
I'll show up and I'll debate them right now. I'll debate them
anywhere. Anywhere they go. Anywhere they go. I'll debate them
immediately. It's like Bro, can you chill? Are you good? Are
you all right? Are you Are you doing okay? Um Jesus, we need
I was going to say a certain phrasing. Can we get one of Destiny's
friends to just go do a check-in with him, just make sure that
it's okay, that he's doing all right. Nothing's a problem.
Right? Can we just make sure of this? I want to be able to jump
in and talk to him. I don't care if I'm streaming or not. Cuz
that like it can't be that these guys are 24/7 constantly chatting
about me always. It's crazy. Dude, he's >> I understand
that and I think you've demonstrated enough that [clears throat]
that problem rule probably needs to change for that reason. Because
if they're going to talk um in my servers and that you have to
be able to respond. I get that. Let's go. Wait, wait, turning
his whole server into a battleground for streamers? I might have
to rejoin. I think I will be banned summarily, but I might have
to rejoin. I'm going to get in that. We just join and stream
the Discords? Let's go. Um Yeah. We can make a change for that
rule. Yeah, we can do that. I can do that. But I Like I said,
if if it's ban this person who hasn't broken any of my rules,
I'm just I'm just not going to. Oh, wait, wait, will not ban
Doobie. Wait, will not ban Doobie. He'll change all the other
rules to keep Destiny around, but he will not ban Doobie.
Destiny, if you're going to be a petty tin pot dictator, if you're
going to be this small-minded dictator Ethan Klein-like figure,
then I'll have to say no. Okay. All right. Okay. I'll be careful.
Is there anything else I can help you with today? Anything uh
You need Um no, not right now. Okay. I'll talk to you later,
Destiny. But be careful. I'll let you bye.
Without a long-term partner, he's got to get somehow, right?
Without a long-term partner, he's got to lean into the meme somehow.
And so it's inventing a blacklist and then done it within a what?
Hour and a half period? Yeah, that's crazy. Dude, he's making
the same face. Hold on, where's the mail time clip? Is he making
the same face as the mail time clip? I think it's mail time again.
There you go.
All right, you got to work.